Steel is the most important material to human
society.
It has been the skeleton of human industry
for centuries, and the advent of the methods
to mass produce it from iron ore was the impetus
to transform human society from a mostly agricultural
lifestyle to urban industrialisation.
It forms the backbone of our skyscrapers,
it paves the way for our railways, it shapes
the engines that powers our society, and the
very tools that forge these objects are made
from steel.
We have spoken before about how the refining
processes of iron determines whether the resulting
material will be steel or iron and how the
exact percentage of carbon present in the
material has dramatic results on the final
material properties, and how the production
methods through time has taken steel from
an expensive material reserved for swords,
armour and toolmaking, to one that has permeated
into nearly every technology we use in our
lives.
But I failed to tell why that simple addition
of carbon has such a huge effect on the iron,
turning it from a relatively weak material
to one capable of launching an industrial
revolution, which is what we are going to
learn about today.
Much of our knowledge in crafting steel was
passed down over the centuries from blacksmith
to blacksmith, creating tools for their communities,
so to learn more about this amazing material
and how blacksmiths carefully tailor it’s
material properties, I visited Alec Steele’s
workshop to create my own knife from scratch.
We started our forging process with round
stock 1055 steel with 0.55% carbon content,
placed it in the forge and gradually shaped
it with a power hammer to a rectangular bar
that could be more precisely shaped into the
shape of our blade using a 3 pound hammer
that my wee arms struggled to swing after
an hour.
Once we had roughed out the shape we began
to grind and refine our blade.
Eventually producing our blade blank that
would later be grinded to it’s final shape,
but before that could happen we needed to
perform some metallurgy wizardry through the
heat treatment process.
To drive home how important this step is,
we tested 4 samples of the same material at
different stages of the heat treatment process.
This was our sample before the heat treatment
process, which you will quickly see was the
weakest of the bunch.
This is the normalised sample, which was ductile
with a low yield stress.
It took several hammer blows, which it absorbed
through plastic deformation, not ideal characteristics
for a sword or knife.
Next we tested our quench hardened sample,
which is stupid and dangerous and should not
be tried at home.
This fractured explosively and tore a hole
through Alec’s reflector.
Finally we tested the tempered material, which
absorbed every hammer blow with minimal plastic
deformation and only broke when we cut a notch
into the material to create a stress concentration
point.
This material is tough, capable of absorbing
energy without deforming permanently, and
hard allowing it to resist damage to the cutting
edge.
It is the ideal material for a blade.
If any of these terms confused you, I created
a video called Material Properties 101 that
you can check out to get a better understanding
of material property terminology.
So how can the same steel alloy change so
radically by simply applying heat?
Well this is the magic of the iron carbon
alloy.
We can careful control how the internal metallic
crystal structure forms with heating and cooling
cycles.
First let’s see how adding carbon to iron
affects it’s crystalline structure.
With no carbon present pure iron will form
a crystal structure called body centred cubic
with an iron atom at each of the eight corners
and another in the centre.
Each crystal structure has a direction it
most easily wants to deform, called a slip
plane.
For body centred cubic the slip plane occurs
along this planes.
Metals with Body centred cubic crystals like
iron and tungsten tend to be harder and less
malleable than metals with face centred cubic
crystals like aluminium, lead and gold.
When a metal is cooling, these crystals grow
from individual nucleation points and form
grains where each grain has the same orientation
of slip plane but neighbouring grains may
not have the same slip plane.
Let’s think about this 2 dimensionally,
when a force is applied, the grain wants to
slip in a particular direction, and passes
the force onto the next grain in that direction
too, but this grains slip plane is at a different
angle, so that force needs to be greater in
order to cause deformation.
It’s like trying to push a train down a
railway track, by pushing on its side.
It’s not going to go anywhere easily.
So smaller and more numerous grains results
in a stronger material.
Pure iron tends to always has the same crystal
structure as it cools and it’s crystal structure
doesn’t change meaningfully with heat treatment.
This is where alloying with carbon comes in.
To explore this let’s look at our phase
diagram for carbon steel.
On this diagram we have our carbon content
percentage on the x-axis and the temperature
of the metal on the y-axis.
This tells us the crystalline structure of
the metal at various temperatures and carbon
contents.
On the left hand side we have pure iron, which
as we explained earlier forms only one crystal
structure, called ferrite.
As we move across the diagram to the right
hand side, less and less of the crystal structure
forms ferrite, and more forms an iron carbide
alloy, commonly called cementire.
Now if we move up in temperature we start
to see these lines that represent transitional
temperatures, where the crystal structures
of the steel begin to transform into a new
crystal structure called Austenite.
Moving further up again we see lines representing
the transition of the material to a liquid
state.
Austenites primary difference to ferrite is
that it forms that face centred cubic crystal
structure that we saw early, while ferrite
is body centred cubic.
And while this packing pattern is denser than
body centred cubic, it does open up spaces
in the crystal structure that interstitial
carbon atoms, which are smaller than iron,
can snuggly fit.
Allowing austenite to have a higher solubility
to carbon over ferrite.
Using all of this information, let’s take
our 1055 steel with 0.55% carbon content and
see how it transforms from the start of our
heat treatment cycle to the end.
The first step is called normalisation.
Normalisation is primarily functions to relieve
internal stresses and strains that formed
during the forging process and return the
material to its original crystal structure
before forging began.
It’s effectively a reset button for the
steel and creates nice even grain size and
distribution, increasing its strength.
Here we placed the knife blank inside a steel
tube to prevent the metal from receiving heat
directly from the flame, but instead a more
even radiative heat from the tube.
Once it reaches this transition temperature
we let it soak to give the crystal structure
time to settle.
The next step in normalising is to allow the
steel to slowly air cool.
What happens now depends on the carbon content.
If we take a 0.8% carbon steel, no hang on
we’re gonna need a bigger graph for this,
If we take a 0.8% carbon steel and cool it
to it’s through transitional temperature
the austenite and the interstitial carbon
will slowly transform to a mixture of ferrite
and cementite, which takes this laminar structure
called pearlite.
Pearlite only forms at a 0.8% carbon solution
Now if we take a 0.55% 0.2% steel, like the
one we used.
And slowly cool it, to its first transitional
temperature here.
Where ferrite first begins to form, ferrite
is pure iron so as it forms the carbon percentage
begins to rise, this will continue to happen
until the remaining austenite has a carbon
percentage of 0.8% and it will then form pearlite
from this point on.
This forms a crystal structure dominated by
ferrite, showing here as a lighter colour,
surrounded by the darker pearlite.
Comparing these microstructures to another
2 we can see the effect carbon has on the
microstructure.
Here we have pure iron, with 100% ferrite,
showing as this light colour, you can even
see the grain boundaries.
This is a 0.5% carbon steel similar to ours,
where a very small amount of ferrite formed
before we reaching the point of pearlite formation,
and this is 0.8% carbon steel where the entire
structure is pearlite, with our previous example
showing pearlite under 500 times magnification
where you can readily see that laminar structure.
How Pearlite strengthens steel is not well
understood.
It has little effect on the steels stiffness,
but increasing the pearlite content has dramatic
effects on the materials yield point, making
it much more capable of absorbing energy without
permanently deforming.
But we can increase the materials stiffness
and hardness with our next step.
If we heat the metal back up to form austenite
once again, but this time instead of letting
it cool slowly, we rapidly cool it in oil,
while casually burning your arm hair off and
barely flinching, the carbon atoms that spread
out throughout the hot austenite structure
cannot diffuse out of the crystal lattice
to form cementite, and instead gets stuck
in solution, creating a new crystal structure
called martensite.
This crystal structure has a huge amount of
internal stretching.
In part because the carbon trapped within
the crystal structure causes the crystal lattice
to deform, but also because during the rapid
cooling the surface cooled much faster than
the internal material.
This causes internal tension in the material.
These internal strains make it harder for
additional deformation to occur, but this
does not make the material stronger.
It simply means it will not stretch and bend
before breaking, and when it finally does
fracture all of this internal tension is suddenly
released in an explosive expansion.
If you have watched Smarter Every Days video
on the Saint Rupert’s Drop, you will have
seen this principle demonstrated in incredible
slow motion.
This material property is called hardness,
and we want our cutting edge to be hard to
resist damage when cutting, but we do not
want our entire blade to be hard as it will
not be able to absorb a lot of energy.
It needs to be able to dissipate some of that
energy through heat and deformation.
This is where the final step of the process
comes in, called tempering.
Tempering raises the temperature enough to
allow the carbon trapped in solution to escape,
we just used an oven set at 200 degree, the
carbon then coalesces to form cementite once
again, but instead of forming pearlite like
before.
It gathers in globules surrounded by ferrite.
Tempering also relieves some of that internal
tension caused by the rapid cooling.This reduces
the hardness, but increases toughness.
This produces a material that has the perfect
balance of characteristics between the normalised
material and the hardened material.
It is ductile enough to absorb hammer blows
without shattering, but strong enough to not
permanently deform, and with enough hardness
to ensure it doesn’t gather damage on the
cutting edge.
This process gave our steel the perfect material
properties and a lot of that is thanks to
the quality of the steel we started off with.
Learning these skills with Alec was a lot
of fun and I highly recommend you check his
channel out.
His incredible attitude to work really inspired
me to start learning some new hands on skills
this year and I am hoping to start that off
by learning how to programme and create robotics
with an arduino.
This course I found on skillshare is the perfect
jumping off point for anyone looking to learn
the same skills.
Skillshare is home to thousands of other classes
in graphic design, animation, web development,
music, photography, video game design and
more.
These days you can teach yourself pretty much
any skill online and Skillshare is a fantastic
place to do it.
With professional and understandable classes,
that follow a clear learning curve, you can
dive in and start learning how to do the work
you love.
.
A Premium Membership begins around $10 a month
for unlimited access to all courses, but you
can get your first 3 months for just 99 cent
if you sign up with this link.This offer was
supposed to be only valid until the end of
Jan, but I talked to Skillshare and was able
to get this extended for ye until Feb 15.
In those 3 months you could easily learn the
skills you need to start a new hobby or business.
So ask yourself right now.
What skill have you been putting off learning.
What project have you been dreaming of completing,
but you aren’t sure if you have the skills
to do it.
Why not start right now and sign up to Skillshare
using the link below.
You have nothing to lose and a valuable life
skill to gain.
As usual thanks for watching and thank you
to all my Patreon supporters.
If you would like to see more from me, the
links to my twitter, facebook and instagram
pages are below.